IAN HOWARD: How do you actually know when things need maintaining?
You either work on a time-schedule basis--
but if you try to save money and try to do maintenance smarter, then
really what you should be doing is on a predictive-condition monitoring basis.
And so that requires the use of sensors--
sensors that actually measure the behavior of the equipment--
can be vibration sensors--
can be pressure-- can be strain gauges--
can be sound microphone sensors.
So these sensors, traditionally, are very expensive,
but now you can get really quite cheap sensors.
And as far as The Internet of Things goes, what you really want to do
is to have those sensors embedded in the equipment with its own power supply
or battery supply or renewable energy--
energy harvesting supply, and then have some means
of digitizing that signature--
whether it's pressure or strain or accelerometer--
acceleration-- and then to be able to communicate that sensor
information to the web.
That's really where the Internet of Things comes in.
So I have here an example of a sensor that we put together
more than 15 years ago.
And this was designed to fit onto large rotating equipment.
And it has inbuilt in there a MEMS transducer, which
measures the acceleration, and also has a thermometer to measure
the temperature of the device.
So when we developed this, we realized that okay the concept really
would be to embed these into remote machines
and often in places that are not very accessible.
So you really don't want to have these battery powered
and then every three months have to actually replace the batteries.
So that brought us into the research topic of energy harvesting.
And there are many different types of energy
we can extract from the environment--
for example, solar or wind energy.
But we've been working-- because we're looking
at vibration-- we've been working on energy harvesting from the vibration
environment.
And there are different techniques for extracting energy,
but we've been looking particularly at the piezoelectric energy harvesting.
So I've got an example here of a piezoelectric beam
that can be used for that.
Here is a miniature piezoelectric beam.
And it would be clamped to the machine.
So it's base-excited vibration, and this beam then vibrates back and forwards.
So what we find is per meter per second squared--
or per g-- you can extract fractions of a milliwatt of energy
from these devices if they're operating at resonance.
Now a fraction of a milliwatt might not sound very much.
But actually, because it's generating power continuously,
over the days, weeks, and months, you accumulate a lot of energy.
And so, then, you can couple that with smart supercapacitors
or other recharging devices to recharge your batteries and so on, which
gives you enough energy-- enough power to be
able to communicate that information from the sensor-- from the smart sensor
to the internet or to the web.
So there's a vast array of applications now
in industry for these kinds of devices.